right here in the lobby of ramsy
solutions Kyle and Elizabeth are with us
hey guys how are you hey Dave we're
doing well welcome better than we
deserve good to have you guys where you
from uh Riverhead New York on Long
Island on Long Island oh nice beautiful
area very cool well welcome to Nashville
and you're here to do your debt-free
scream I hear yes sir cool and how much
have you paid off $72,500 all right and
how long did that take you took us 3
years three years what kind of money uh
we started at about 24,000 and ended at
80 at 80 wow it's a huge increase during
the 3 years what you do to increase your
income that much Elizabeth got a job oh
okay that'll do it there's more to it
than that I was living overseas with
Harding University's international study
abroad program and after we got married
Elizabeth joined me over there and she
couldn't use her Speech Pathology while
she was there until we moved back uh to
the states gotcha okay so you're speech
pathologist all right very cool and and
what do you do Kyle uh we both work for
Timothy Hill Children's Ranch there in
Riverhead New York and okay we uh we're
caretakers and we also work as
administrators and teachers there very
neat so what happened three years ago
tell me your story of getting out of
debt well three years ago is when we got
married three years this month so that
amount is our combined amount from when
we got married but it's all student debt
um and when we got married um I had been
working on mine individually and he had
as well mhm M I had heard about Dave
Ramsey and had friends that had taken
your classes but I wasn't really on a
specific plan just trying to knock it
out as I could and when I married Kyle
he was um had a plan and showed me you
know the Deb snowball and explained
everything and so got me on board and
said this is how we're going to do it
and so that's what we did then we went
about the business of doing it EXA cool
exactly okay so how much how long have
you been doing what you're currently
doing with the with that particular
Ranch uh with Timothy old children Ranch
we we have been there 2 years
okay so two of the three you were making
the 80 uh or there abouts there was an
increase in there okay all right but but
the 24 was just for the first portion in
other words of this and and then cuz
that makes the math work in my head as
I'm looking at paying off
$73,000 that's very impressive so you
guys are obviously very Ministry minded
yes sir and uh and have you know chosen
to live out your careers in that
methodology using that way and uh and
yet have found a way they furnish
housing where you are so you don't have
housing cost one of the blessings uh
that that we have working with the ranch
and one thing also that we've done Dave
is while we've been there and been
teaching we came in 2014 to the
financial Coach master Series so both of
us are coaches uh up there in Riverhead
and with our residents and others in the
area wow very cool well thank you for
doing that so you're spreading this
around good job and we also we also use
your curriculum the foundations and
personal finance uh with our residents
yeah with the kids huh so how many kids
are at this Ranch uh right now we have
about 50 and we range from about 13
years old to 25 very neat very neat well
thank you guys thank you very much thank
you and congratulations how's it feel
three years in to actually be here and
be debt free it's very exciting it feels
great yeah we're it's like a burden
that's lifted so feel like we can
actually do stuff now with our
money came in with the plan and you know
and activated and we wanted to to finish
and finish strong and uh as as we were
getting married
uh and wanting to to start a family we I
knew that the importance of of doing
that debt-free and just the way they
will give us the opportunity to to do
more and to serve more and to give more
you know as as you teach and as you say
and um we're just blessed to to be able
to do that and now that um we're
expecting our first child uh in June hey
this year all right congratulations
thank you so as you guys were going
through this I'm sure the folks at the
ranch were very supportive obviously but
did you have people off in the distance
throwing grenades and going yeah you
guys are kind of wacky not really
throwing grenades but I mean we had
people who um you know like the good for
you but not really that's not really our
thing Pat you on the head yeah kind
aren't you sweet yeah so that's so
demeaning I love it well congratulations
you guys very cool so I mean you're
counselors your coaches you've been
through our training you're teaching the
kids the same stuff there at the ranch
you've done it what are the secrets to
getting out of
debt well I mean one thing for me I
would say is just being consistent um
you know we have our monthly budget
meetings and that's something I wasn't
doing um before we married and um just
being consistent and setting our
priorities correctly um each month as
we're deciding where's the money going
to go and we really got to attack the
debt first and once we do that then we
can do the other things and so the
consistency I would say very cool like
that and and and Dave you mentioned in
your books but that being content and
being happy with what you have and not
being in want and as we look through
psalms and and David talks about you
know the Lord is our shepherd I shall
not be in want and not wanting and and
taking that plan and saying this is what
I want to do in X number of years and
following through and doing that and so
as it's been a challenge for us to be
debt free we've told that to our
residents that we live with that hey
here's the debt we have we don't want
you to follow in that footsteps and we
want to lead and we want to to show you
that you can overcome obstacles and uh
now here we are there you go yeah and
and you you know you've been another
type of example to them one more type of
witness to them and they get to see this
this sharp young couple starting their
family completely debt-free it's a great
model for these kids of the ranch really
is congratulations thank you very very
well done I love it well I'm very proud
of you guys I'm proud that we had a
little part to in this and uh we
appreciate all the things you're doing
to help others with the information very
cool stuff Kyle and Elizabeth from Long
Island New York
$73,000 paid off in three years making
24 to 80,000 during that time new baby
on the way life is good count it down
let's hear a debt-free Scream 3 2 1
we're done free
H way to go you two very very well done
I love it
congratulations man that is fabulous you
know why most people don't
win they don't
bother you have to bother you have to be
intentional never again is American
Express going to call my house and ask
my wife why she would stay with a man
that won't pay his bills
[Music]
oh